hello flesh I'm Shintaro a sermon from
Japan Savior the Minister of Education
in the UK or it could change the
chemistry education in the world how
would you specifically change it the
answer to your question is that I have
no idea but what I do know is that most
of the approaches that have been used in
the past don't work very well when I was
at school they brought in a new scheme
when the students had to learn
everything by doing experiments and this
worked quite well but it was too slow
they had to spend far too much time in
the lab to learn quite simple things and
so I think the really important thing is
that any country I think shouldn't teach
chemistry in just one way because if the
minister decides chemistry should be
taught like this the Minister may well
be wrong but if there are several
different schemes with the luck half of
them will be okay even if they're harder
half of them don't work very well so
you're not putting all your children
through the same system and it will also
make them think differently hello
professor not to mention that I like
your hair very much I have rather
suggestions not questions I want to
suggest you to come onto the television
platform there you can make with various
documentaries about the same videos that
you have prepared on and another thing
would be why don't you make a separate
video about the names of elements I
think the answer to your question is
that making full-length television films
is very time consuming and also it's
very expensive and so you have to go to
and a professional organisation like the
BBC you have to have a script and it
takes many months whereas some of our
videos and made very quickly when the
name was announced for copernicium from
the
that we saw the announcement to the time
my video was on YouTube with four hours
and if we had made a professional
television program it would still be
being edited nearly a year later and
your suggestion about the names of
elements I think is a good one but I'm
not sure that people would like to watch
just that and I think it's some
information that we should try and add
we're in our new videos because that
could be interesting for people but I'd
like them to know more about the
chemistry of the element and just why it
was called the particular name what is
your main contribution to the world as a
scientist and what is your new
innovation in field of chemistry I think
the answer your first question is quite
easy I think my main contribution has
been teaching people chemistry I mean
eventually may turn out that some of the
things I've discovered are very
important or it may turn out that
they're all not very important but the
main thing is that I have used my
research to train people to solve
problems in all sorts of different areas
so I have students now working all sorts
of different areas of Industry doing
research on all sorts of things and it's
probably for teaching them to do that
that is the thing that I'm most proud of
I've got two of my students and now
professors at Nottingham and so I'm
really quite proud of this and I think
it's rather people to judge what is my
best piece of work
I'm sorry I forgot what the second
question was what was my greatest
innovation I think that scientifically I
have promoted the use of supercritical
fluids as solvents for chemical
reactions though I've done some other
things that I think are quite
interesting as well and I think it's
important for you all to realize that
most scientists work in several
different areas
so the thing that you start working on
when you're 20 is not necessarily the
thing that you will be working on when
you're 77 if you could be any element
which would he be and why that's a very
good question has another question
nobody's ever asked me I think I
probably like to be xenon which is
because xenon is quite a peaceful
element but it will react if it's really
roused by something like fluorine and
it's also it's an element which i think
is very interesting and it has strange
properties and I really enjoyed working
with xenon it's also very expensive and
valuable which I think also reflects
well but I don't know which element
would you like to be